Speaker 1: Let's continue our tour through the
United States over the last 24 hours. Donald
Trump last night held his first sort of real
campaign event. This was an event in Davenport,
Iowa. It was billed as a major speech about
education policy. It ended up being nearly
100 minutes of Donald Trump ranting and
raving, confused and with terrible audio,
very, very little discussion of education other
than a few anti-trans statements. Now, I do want
to warn you, as we get into these clips, the audio
was absolutely terrible. It's possible that Antifa
snuck in and did the audio engineering If you
haven't heard of Antifa. In the next segment, you
will be introduced to the ways of Antifa by one of
the attendees at this event. First and foremost,
the disconnect from the real world continues as
Donald Trump claimed that you need an ID to buy
groceries. Why don't you need one to vote?
Speaker 3: You have to have one when you
buy groceries and other things, but you
can't have one for voting. That's because
they want to cheat. That's the only reason.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, you don't need an ID
to buy groceries. And when I tweeted about
this, someone wrote to me and said, David,
if you use a credit card, you do need an ID to
buy groceries. No, you do not in the not in the
United States. In the rare case, when you have
a physical card and you wrote on the back side
and you hand it to a cashier, they might make you
show an ID, but overwhelmingly you don't need any
ID whatsoever in any circumstance to buy groceries
unless you are buying alcohol. But Trump wouldn't
know that because he has not, I guess, bought
groceries in probably decades. Donald Trump went
fully conspiratorial during this supposed speech
about education, where he said he will end WOAK
and will also crush the deep state.
Speaker 3: Together, we will end
the era of weaponized government forever. We
will end walk. We will crush the deep state.
Speaker 1: There it is, the deep state, which,
of course, is a conspiracy theory that Donald
Trump has continued to dabble with for a very,
very long time. One of the strangest moments
during this event was when Donald Trump told the
audience about whether they like their children.
Very unusual presidential sort of speech moment.
Speaker 3: Does anybody here not like their
children? Oh, I would be careful.
Speaker 2: Oh.
Speaker 3: We got to be careful with that.
Speaker 1: I mean, Trump doesn't,
right? Not not most of them anyway.
Speaker 3: The problem is the fake news media
is going to report that as fact. You know that
you're going to have a lot of explaining to do.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: He loves his boy. He loves his family.
Speaker 1: And as you can tell, the audio, very,
very poor. Cutting in and out. At another moment,
Donald Trump tells this bizarre story of he
would win basketball by having LeBron James play
on a women's team, which is an interesting idea.
Speaker 3: I'm not a fan of LeBron James. I don't
like LeBron, but I'd say, Hey, LeBron, do you ever
think of becoming a woman because you're going to
be on my game, going to have to go undefeated for
the next five years. LeBron. I'm not a fan, but,
you know, I would ask him that question. There it
is. And I will not give one penny to any school
that has a vaccine mandate or a mask mandate.
Speaker 1: That really set the crowd off. The
crowd, mostly like the crowd was very bored
throughout 95% of the speech. They liked the
anti-vax stuff and they liked the anti-trans
stuff. Trump also now regularly using the word
insane asylum, is falsely claiming that foreign
countries are emptying their insane asylums into
the United States. It's not happening. And
Trump reflects on the political correctness
of the term insane asylum. Here we go.
Speaker 3: Since they're empty, they're
mental institutions. They're insane. Asylum.
So word you're not supposed to use anymore.
Words you're not supposed to is crying like
Biden. I have three words for you to get.
We don't want to be caught
in that predicament. So two words insane asylum.
These are words you're not supposed to be using
anymore. It's not politically incorrect, but.
Speaker 1: It's not politically incorrect. I
think it means it's not politically correct. But
he's as confused as everybody in the crowd. And
I want people to really understand this went on
for nearly 100 minutes and then he took questions.
Trump did go after Ron DeSantis a little bit.
He is unhealthily obsessed with the Santos,
even though DeSantis hasn't yet announced a
candidacy. Trump is daily talking about DeSantis.
Speaker 3: Okay. So remember
this. Ron DeSantis today
decided to sanctimonious dissent. So Ron DeSantis
strongly opposed ethanol. Do you know that? Right.
And we don't even know if he's running, but I
might as well tell you if he's not running. I was
saying he was fine on ethanol. Don't worry about.
Speaker 1: Trump admitting many of his
attacks are just opportunistic lies.
Speaker 3: Strongly opposed to ethanol
and fought against it at every turn. And he's
going to do that again because people that
come out early for something, that's where
they go. That's where it is. So, you know,
he may do something politically, but he was very,
very bad on ethanol as you fought it all the way.
And he also fought against Social Security. He
wanted to decimate it and voted against it three
times, voted against Social Security. That's
a bad one. A lot of people don't know that.
Speaker 1: But yeah, now it's also not exactly
true, and I've spoken about that before. If you're
confused, like a lot of people were dipping in
and out of my livestream last night and saying,
I don't understand what this is about. Even
people who watched the entire speech didn't
know what it was about. It didn't make any sense.
Trump announcing that he will be breaking up the
Department of Education, by which I think he means
abolishing it, which is a very bad idea. In fact,
this entire speech is sort of emblematic of the
problem with education in the United States not
being regulated enough at the federal level. But
in any case, Trump says he'll break up the GOP
and then seems confused himself.
Speaker 3: Selects somebody who.
In addition, I am going to pursue
and we studied it very closely and
I was getting ready to do it, pull the trigger.
Speaker 1: He was about to do it and then he lost.
Speaker 3: The long term goal. But now it's
a short term goal of breaking up the federal
Department of Education and redistributing. It's
functions to the stage. There you go. I'm going
to break it up soon. That'll be done quickly.
I was ready to get it done. I was ready to get
it done. Then we had a bad election.
Speaker 1: Oh, man. He was just days
away. Four years. He couldn't get it done. He
was days from doing it. And then we had a bad
election. Just like his health care plan.
Trump then ended his event in Iowa before
moving to the question phase, which was even
worse, if you can imagine, by promising to use
federal law enforcement to police cities.
Speaker 3: In any Democrat run state. And
it's just not the same. It doesn't work. You
look at these cities are great. Cities are
New York City is a crime Den Chicago is a crime
den. You look at these great cities, Los Angeles,
San Francisco, you look at what's happening
to our country. We cannot let it happen any
longer. And one of the other things I'll do,
because, you know, you're supposed to not be
involved in that. You have to be asked
by the governor or the mayor to come in.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's basically the law.
Speaker 3: The next time I'm not waiting.
One of the things I did was let them run it,
and we're going to show how bad a job they
do what we did that we don't have to wait any
longer. We got to get crime out of our cities.
Thank you very much for a good question.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So he'll send in federal
law enforcement to police to police cities.
Now, the legality of that is very shaky. And
there are cases when the federal government can
just send in law enforcement, but there have to
be specific activities going on. It has to
be things under the purview, for example,
of the FBI or the DEA or ATF. There needs to be
specific expertise or jurisdiction like organized
crime or drug trafficking or terrorism. You can't
just say, oh, we're going to police Chicago for
the hell of it. That's the blanket use of federal
forces to police cities. And it is not obvious at
all that it is legal. But who cares, right? Who
cares? So what I wonder is what's the take away
from people who go to a speech like this? Do they
come? You know, it was billed as a major speech
on education, other than saying, I will end the
Department of Education and like stop transgender,
whatever that means. He didn't really talk about
education. So I wonder, do people go to this and
then go home and say, wow, that was really great,
really electric inspirational speech. I don't know
what the reaction is, especially since people seem
so bored by the 100 minutes of this nonsense. Now,
one other note. Trump did take questions
and it went about as poorly as you would
imagine. Here's one that came from the crowd.
Speaker 3: We'll take one or two more. Go
ahead. Hello, miss. Hello, Mr. Pratt. Got to
be a good one. You know, if it's a good one,
I'm out of here, right? This is a bad one.
Else. I've got to take a couple of more to
get over the stench over the bedroom.
Speaker 2: I just wanted to say it's
an honor to hear you speak. Thank you. But my
question for you is, what can you do to combat
transgender athletes in over women's sport?
Speaker 1: Such an important issue.
Speaker 3: Well, you've done it here because
your governor has passed legislation. You
can't you know, it's crazy. It's it's like how
does. People are seriously in favor of having
it done. And I don't understand it. And I tell
the story of that champion swimmer and she's
there and she's look it up and down the line.
She sees friends that she's been swimming with.
She's a champion. And then she sees this person
next to her and he's a monster. He looks like
Wilt Chamberlain, but a little bit different.
She sees the guy has a wingspan. She's like
looking up and down and she looks up like, wow.
Speaker 1: So do not adjust your television.
Do not adjust your mobile
phone. Trump is not answering
the question. He's just ranting confusedly.
Speaker 3: And, you know, he broke all these
records and it's just a it doesn't make sense.
Speaker 1: All right. There you go. So there
is Trump's question and answer phase.
We are in for a year of this, folks,
and it is as dangerous as it is delusional.
And as we are now focusing on. This is what
Trump said. But what about the attendees
at this speech? Let's talk about that next.